the best view in the world
[Music]
in front of the cabin
about to say is not
once
some of the equivalent to a hundred
thousand just a hundred pounds can teach
up to ten people how to pray Salah we
aren't saying we bring people to omra
but we teach brothers and sisters like
Khalid how to pray Salah and praise all
this Allah for four days praise the
janaza praise the jumma praise it praise
all their five salons the donor gets the
reward so do not miss on this reward
click the button or the link and donate
thank you
okay
brothers and sisters and dear friends so
there is a common question or a common
that uh a lot of Muslims have which is
very simply and let's get straight to
the point inshallah is that thus not
praying invalidate your fast
that is the question let me give you the
mic alhamdulillah
now this question that we know that many
people they just come forward to answer
by you know it yes it's value the one
who doesn't doesn't pray their fasting
is valid and someone put themselves as
well forward to say no the one who is
not fasting is invalid
and both sides they have kind of a point
but we need to understand these things
is not yes an old question we need to
understand the fundamentals behind it we
need to know is that is the is the Salah
is a condition for the one for for the
validity of the of the faster owner
that's that's um that's the key thing
because if we say fasting will be
invalid if the person doesn't pray that
means uh the the Salah is a condition
for fasting and and that's what we need
to understand where this root where this
principle came from and what's the root
of this principle now this goes back to
the point where if the Salah now is a if
the Salah if the one who leaves the
Salah is a Muslim or not a Muslim and
that matter is debated by Scholars of
Islam now I will present certain Hadith
that the first Hadith that the prophet
salallahu he says
there is nothing between the person and
in the circle of disbelief except
foreign
and and that's why we'll find some of
the salaf some of the sahaba and the
salaf and and and uh and the tabihin uh
generally that have been and the self
generally and there is a statement by
Imam Ahmed that the one who leaves us
Allah
out of laziness whether he lift the
Salah out of uh whatever reason
of the fault of Islam now if the if the
person believes if the person if the
person believes and these Scholars
respect their Scholars and there are
many as well Scholars of Islam believes
this including that a statement
he was talking about even this
particular case and he says as well
talking about the one that even the one
he even thought Alaska as as it was
mentioned that
all his actions nullified that shows has
been all his old actions has been
nullified now there are the other side
so that's the an opinion you're saying
that is that is an opinion which
believes the one who lives and all his
actions is invalid because he's a cover
now the question is does that applies to
the whatever the other Hadith and now
we'll come to this Hadith the the first
Hadith which I'll be bringing is the
Hadith of the prophet salallahu
hesitated
that the first thing that the person
will be questioning the day of judgment
is his prayer
then if his Salah is correct then he is
going to be amongst the successful ones
if there is some deficiency in that
Salah then Allah will say
to the angel see if my servant has
involuntary Deeds and these
voluntarilities will be replaced with
the which is like the voluntary prayer
will be replaced with the deficiency
that he has missed and it will be done
with all of his other obligations in
Islam now that Hadith that shows the one
who lives sometimes the salahira and
there or he has divisions in his Salah
we say there is no making up for the one
who deliberately there is no making up
for that Salah but when you say to the
person to do more voluntarily that's why
we say you know the person lived one
Salah to Salah in his life we don't say
that you could do there is
you have to go back to do more
volunteers and to do more of the
voluntary prayer in order to replace the
Salah that you missed maybe Allah will
replace it in the day of judgment to
gain forgiveness so that's why to say to
do to tell about Allah and to do
Islam to rectify and to follow the evil
Dees with righteous these and that
include the voluntary prayer now another
Hadith that the prophet sallallahu which
he says the
that in the day of judgment a person
will be brought to Allah
and then Allah will ask him and then he
has 99 Scrolls 99 Scrolls of evil Deeds
99 not 1 99 and each scroll as far as
his side could see lion in the day of
judgment all the way to the end and not
one 91 of them all evil Deeds then Allah
will say to the to the person do you
have any good deeds then he will say no
Allah I have I haven't done anything
good and then Allah will say to him and
today will be not wrong you will be not
oppressed and it will be brought up
we wrote him a card this authenticated
from his heart
and then it will be placed on one side
of the scale and all the rectangular
Scrolls beyond the other side
will overweigh all this 99 Scrolls off
of light of evil Deeds subscribe they
said you have to bring the conditions of
like just to pray the Salah to do these
things that if if he has implemented
what what Allah implies as some scholar
they said which he has to pray what
Allah didn't you know why wasn't written
for him
so if he has done something more Allah
will write it Allah will be it will be
written to him it will be commanded to
be written for him he will be not
prevented to be written and everything
will be known and Allah Allah will Road
him for the things that he has done if
he has done it Allah will mention that
to him but he did he didn't do it Allah
will say Allah will bring Allah for on
the day of judgment it will be brought
to him and this is
so that that's Hadith and that pretty
much the Hadith which our
used to debate to say that the one who
leaves the Salah is not a cafe he's
still he's still a Muslim he's still
within the fold of Islam he's not a
kafir and that is supported by even one
of the statement of Imam
because he has two statements sometimes
he said another another situation he
said he's not a cafe which was supported
as well by an Imam
Allah which he which he brought as will
statement by Imam by Imam Ahmed to say
the one who lives the Salah is not the
clever out of laziness now and we don't
say that the one who Allah all the one
who leaves us Allah
all of them are Muslims no we don't say
this we say the one who leaves the Salah
denying the salah's obligation
he said to him it was said to him this
is the question he said if the one
doesn't pray what about his zakat his
Siam the fasting and all of these things
this is a question and it's recorded
and then he said he said uh he said the
two things he said either the person who
leaves the Salah either we say he's a
kafir if he's a kafir that he has to
know that he said that if he says that
the Salah is only kind of practical it's
just a gymnastic thing that you do it in
the morning and and I could do different
things this person
but he but if the other side the one who
says he leaves us Allah out of laziness
to say you know I'm lazy Rectify me you
know
you know you know and sometimes he said
we'll try to do my best inshallah I'm
trying to rectify myself he said this is
we cannot judge he is a kaffir we can't
unless if he was under an Islamic ruler
and this Islamic ruler will will judge
him to he will be given doing istitaba
for three days will be jailed or two or
three days and he will be presented to
the capital punishment and if he choose
the capital punishment over than the
Salah then in that case this person out
of the fold of Islam then in that case
he said that's what checklist will
approve this that he
Islam supported this he is out of the
Fall there's no way to bring this one
because he choose to die rather than to
rather than to pray now on the other
side if someone start praying what shall
he do this is the question if he is a
Catholic the question is within these
three days if he start praying someone
he didn't pray for a month let's say and
he will be jailed for three days he is
he commanded the question is within
these three days what he's commended to
do to do what but if he's not a Muslim
how is he going to pray he has to bring
the shadow so that's why we don't say he
is you know he is
we say he is if he prays within these
three days and he choose to pray that
he's a Muslim alhamdulillah he comes
back to Islam he goes back to proper
practicing Islam yeah and then that's
what he said and he said
going back to what he says and he said
now it is we cannot judge because we
can't say that's why we cannot assume
the person
you start praying sisters who are
praying you do that it's that we advise
we remind the people Etc and we cannot
judge this person is a kaffir unless if
the person denies the obligation
is not something is important or you
know Etc of the statement then in that
case he said either he said the verbilly
with his tongue or with his heart
meaning he not necessarily has to say it
but he knows in his heart he doesn't
like he doesn't like he doesn't he hates
Allah he had to follow the Islam
again this one African even the prophet
salaam he dealt with them according to
the appearance of Islam and if they
fulfill them so that's the condition
that to do that so going back to the
point so the same thing as other
obligation of Islam the person will be
uh the person will be uh will be just
according to the to their deeds and if
the person leaves the Salah or some of
the Salah and we say if he is out of
laziness I will say to him Rectify
yourself with Allah you know go back to
practice Islam and if he if he if he
fast or he do this still is acceptable
from them according to the statement of
the sheriff
now and according to the statement of
other Scholars as well of Islam so
that's why the question is oh the answer
is not yes or no question the answer is
has a context and has an understanding
so if someone in total who says
the person who lives
all his deeds are nullified and means
that Allah will not accept that his
efforts or or Etc and it has different
meanings and that shows as well the same
Hadith which is which says the one who
lives once Allah and of Allah will Allah
will ask the Angels see from for myself
if he has the deficiency that if he has
any any voluntary it is to be replaced
with his obligatory Salah so that's why
again we we say that the answer is not
yes and no and we say the person that
this things is accepted and this is
supported Again by even Imam one of the
one of his statements and other and
other Scholars as well to say that the
person as well is blameworthy for solely
Dean for the fundamentals of Islam and
furora and even the branches of Deen
that includes the Salah The Siam the
Hajj Etc so the person is so if someone
doesn't pray and it doesn't mean he has
to leave everything in Islam if someone
doesn't pray until we say to him start
praying start to rectify yourself and as
will do your duties as a Muslim do what
you can yeah maybe maybe this person
will will come back to practice Islam
any more and that's why even the schools
of Islam they said are the people who
are the The Who for the disbeliever are
they blameworthy for the for the for
that practicing for the salawat for the
for the prayer for the fasting for these
things even some school believe they are
they will be punished for that some
scholar they said because those are from
the branches of Islam yeah so they have
to be they have to be done so that's why
this is that's why we say to the people
and that's what this is saying
is a Muslim and is judged and is
blameworthy for the things that leaves
from the obligations of Islam the same
thing the person is rewarded for the
things that he do from the obligations
of Islam now except there's wonder why
Imam Ahmad to say he's a cover supported
by as well which we respect and we all
know and as well but if you if you read
the context of Inspector we don't say
that is the opinion that is the only
opinion we respect it yeah we respect it
and actually if if people who understood
sheikhism properly he was talking about
the one who is presented to the capital
punishment and choose not to pray that
shows this person is as a cover so
that's what Imam supported this that's
what our sheikhil al-bani supported this
and he said that shows what is in his
heart he has the hatred to Islam and
hatred to practice Islam to the extent
he preferred to
that shows what is in his heart and but
that's all you find that's what some
Scholars even the Contemporary schools
believes us the one who lives as a cafe
and all the other actions is is is
nullified and and by the way as well
includes that they said their marriage
is void
everything is void there the B has not
valid yeah there are many things that
who they believe that if they slaughter
the slaughter is not valid if their
marriage is invalid all of these things
that which applies to to applies to a
Muslim doesn't it doesn't apply to them
but the other eyes will have the other
side as well the vast majority of those
of the schools of Islam believes that
actually is still a Muslim but he is but
it doesn't mean again we don't say he's
doing sugar because we say he's a good
person that the the word sin after shirk
below just below is living the Salah
says in the Quran the angels will ask
them
yes exactly so it's a it's a major sin
it is the biggest sin even the schools
of Islam it is enough as there are some
scholar they said it is enough evil for
the one who leaves the Salah or someone
who who doesn't doesn't do this Allah on
time it's enough even that the school of
Islam did debate if he's a Muslim or not
Muslim can you imagine it shows if the
scholars of Islam they so is he a Muslim
or not a Muslim they debate yeah they
know well that shall we accept him so
that's why it's a big thing it's not
something so that's why we say to the
brothers and sisters we start praying
and ask Allah you know to to guide you
to Islam to guide you to the way of
Islam and the guidance of Islam and
prayer and that's something which is
important and and again and and and
subhanallah try your best in Charlotte
to make sure that when you fast you want
to tell them pleasure of Allah so that's
why how do you end the pleasure of Allah
are you disobeying him by not praying by
not doing the other righteousness
if you want to follow Sheikh Muhammad's
YouTube channel inshallah he'll be
discussing more of these topics uh
inshallah we've got brother wrestling
with the heater uh but yeah if you if
you can inshallah if you want to follow
Sheikh Mohammed on his channel I'll put
a link here inshallah you can see uh go
follow him inshallah and go to YouTube
channel he'll be doing more videos of
this nature maybe discussions in the
base Etc if you have if you want to have
any questions we'll probably do a live q
a very soon inshallah check that out and
don't forget in our Solar plus project
brother sisters we are teaching people
how to praise Salah since we're talking
about Salah you can have a Sada khajare
for you by donating towards this cause
inshallah and teaching maybe 10 people
20 people 30 people how to pray Salah
imagine them learning fast here for the
first time and may Allah make this a
beneficial month for us from sisters and
protect us from backbiting while it's
sad that I'm seeing people who are
fasting
backbiting the prophet saws said Allah
is free Allah doesn't is staying away
from food and water if you can if you're
not going to stop lying and backbiting
yeah and the process said Allah promises
Jannah for the one who guarantees what's
between his lips and what's between his
legs around sisters so let's avoid
backbiting and talking we can differ
with each other but may Allah protect us
inshallah and may Allah bless you guys
do not forget to subscribe YouTube
channel for more of these discussions
inshallah till next time